do you remember
when joe biden said that he opposed
vaccine mandates
well now he's he's completely
changed his point of view so for quite a
long time he said i oppose it i oppose
it i oppose it now he of course is
attempting to issue vaccine mandates and
here's how he explains this change in
his perspective
should police officers emergency
responders be mandated to get vaccines
and if not should they be
stay at home or let go yes and yes
[Applause]
by the way
by the way i waited until uh
july
to talk about mandating because i tried
everything else possible
the mandates are working
all the stuff about people leaving and
people goodness you have you have
everyone for united airlines to spirit
all these airlines we're not going to
get
all
96 97 percent of the people have gotten
the vaccine all the talk about all these
folks who are going to leave the
military if they're mandated not true
you got about a 90 some percent
vaccination rate
so
joe biden is fudging the numbers a
little bit here because it's true that a
lot of organizations are getting up to
pretty high levels of vaccination but a
lot of organizations are also laying a
ton of people off united airlines what
was it last week or two weeks ago fired
something like 600 employees because
they didn't want to take the fouchy
aochie so sure other organizations are
doing this too people are quitting
people are letting their contracts
expire people are being fired outright
so sure that's when you fire all the
unvaccinated people then your numbers
for vaccination are going to go up but
but in a lot of cases companies
including airlines are pushing back
against the mandates delta airlines one
of the biggest
kind of a liberal airlines one of the
biggest airlines in the united states
though just came out last week and
backtracked and said no we're not going
to force our guys to get the vaccine
they don't want to get it it's wrong
we're going to lose a lot of our of our
fleet and so we're just not going to do
it we're going to back off that mandate
southwest the same thing there was a
sick out a couple of weeks ago on
southwest airlines the pilots and the
other workers didn't want to get the
vaccine and so southwest is backing off
the mandate now they've come out and
said we oppose the vaccine mandate
police departments are dealing with this
chicago pd they're expecting 40 to 50
percent to walk off the force tsa tsa
has reportedly had a number of sick outs
this is al also one of the reasons why
the airlines were all screwed up a
couple of weeks ago i am not sure that a
sponsor for this show has ever come in
at a more opportune time than get upside
what does get upside do
saves you money on gas certainly needed
right now our listeners are making up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up how's it work just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code knowles canon wles get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back do not pay full price at the pump
anymore it's crazy get cash back using
get upside down load the app for free
use promo code knowles canon wlis to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cashback
on your first tank some people who drive
a lot are making as much as two or three
hundred dollars a month in cash back and
there's no catch the cash back gets
added right to your account you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
an e-gift card for amazon and other
brands just download the free get upside
app use promo code knowles canon wles
get up to 50 cents per gallon cashback
on your first tank that is code knowles
k-w-l-e-s
alright also joe biden is making these
really strong claims the mandates work
the mandates work well yeah it works if
you fire all of the people who aren't
going to go along with it but you're
going to have serious
economic and political repercussions
from that what does this boil down to
boils down to people's right to make in
this case their own medical decisions
when they don't face a grave risk from
the virus necessary for most people when
the vaccine is brand new it uses in some
cases brand new vaccine technology there
have been proven side effects some of
which have been deadly that's why they
paused one of the vaccines what does joe
biden say he laughs he scoffs at your
silly idea of freedom
the two things that concern me
one are those who just try to make this
a political issue freedom
i have the freedom to kill you
with my copy no i mean come on freedom
free come on freedom ugh disgust you
[ __ ] you peepee peasants freedom
what you have the freedom to kill people
with your if you are unvaccinated this
is what joe biden's saying if you're
unvaccinated you are putting the
vaccinated people at risk because if you
have the vaccine
you can't spread the virus and you can
you can't contract the virus presumably
but you certainly as joe biden is
implying here can't spread it to others
except that isn't true even if you're
vaccinated you can still spread it to
others this is what the cdc said at the
end of july this is why
the vaccinated are still being required
to wear masks according to cdc guidance
this is why
people are being told to socially
distance and still take all of these
precautions
this is why people are being told maybe
don't go to christmas this year maybe
you don't go to thanksgiving this year
this is this is why all of these things
are happening so it's it's
both in the particular the idea that
once you're vaccinated everything's
totally fine that's being contradicted
by the cdc the idea that you're go the
vaccinated are at great risk because of
the unvaccinated is being contradicted
by the cdc because we're still being
told if you're vaccinated you have a
very low risk of hospitalization or
death and in the broad
principle here the idea that americans
are are just too wedded to their freedom
and you got to give up your freedom and
take the fauchiachi whether it's the the
president telling you to do so whether
it's the occupational safety and health
administration telling you to do so
whether it's all these kind of
bureaucrats and technocrats
whose power i can't exactly locate in
the american political tradition
it's a contempt for your freedom it's a
contempt for your way of life it's a
contempt
for you and it's never going to end by
the way i'm so glad that you liked that
clip i liked it too i did i liked that
you liked it i'm glad that you're here
and we're here together i want to be
together a lot more okay
in order for that to happen you have to
ring that bell you have to subscribe you
have to head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play wherever
you get your podcasts you type in
michael knowles show subscribe
it'll just come directly into your
podcast feed it's free
you will be up you will not get the
censored version you're going to get
the
totally politically incorrect
disallowed on most big tech platforms
point of view i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you